I think people now are more afraid of
death than they've ever been because
they're not familiar with it because it
seems like this exotic other if every
single person has ever lived has died it
can't be that bad right I can't imagine
how one wouldn't be fascinated by death
[Music]
my name is Johanna Evans Dean I'm the
creative director and co-founder of the
morbid anatomy Museum the name morbid
Anatomy seems to suggest to a lot of
people something more like the American
morbidity Museum and American Horror
Story and so people will come in and be
like where the dead babies are like no
we don't you know have dead babies here
there's two parts in the museum there's
the temporary exhibition which is always
borrowed from different private
collectors and there's this rumor in
which is the morbid anatomy library I
think a lot of people who like this this
project are people who had to choose at
a certain point between art and science
I always wanted to be a scientist and I
wanted to be an artist so I'm always
interested and drawn to artifacts from
time periods before those things were
divided up these ideas that death and
beauty art and science cute and horrific
have to be separate when I was a kid I
loved animals and I loved live animals I
loved my cat but also I loved looking at
animals the Natural History Museum or no
jarn formaldehyde my college friends
would call me morbid because I like to
pick up roadkill and preserve the skins
I never stopped doing it but I was
cognizant to the fact that people
thought I was a freak really for
starting the museum that's when I really
discovered there's so many more people
like me than I ever suspected
[Music]
you
[Music]